ils ont consacré à richard bohringer
allocation du spectacle l'ultime
conviction du désir à l'elysée
montmartre 26 mars à 20h30
et franchement richard bohringer à
l'elysée on en rêve bonsoir
richard piccoli alors dire que cette
ultime conviction du désir c'est à
partir du roman là qu'on peut trouver
maintenant chez j'ai lu alors un
spectacle sur scène d'abord je dois dire
moi que j'aime recevoir richard
bohringer merci voilà qu'est ce qu'on va
trouver sur scène se voit ce qu'on va y
aller on va y être au 26 mars à 20h30 à
l'elysée alors qu'est ce qu'on trouve
sur cette erreur il ya des musiciens des
collègues
ouais c'est ça va être un groupe avec la
kora c'est un instrument de un des
grands instruments de la savane du mali
c'est l'instrument mystique magique la
percu et la basse donc si trois
musiciens africains
alors il ya un autre ouvrage que je
trouve très intéressant ces carnets du
sénégal texte de richard branger et
virginie broquet alors qui a réalisé ces
superbes illustrations alors la légende
dit que richard bohringer a trouvé cette
jeune fille en train de dessiner sa
maison à saint louis du sénégal c'est
comme ça qu'ils sont rencontrés c'est
vrai c'est pas exactement comme ça je
suis parti de saint louis avec le
chamelier avec un gros camion avec les
chameliers est arrivé à dakar le
couscoussier de nuit qui devait
m'emmener en gambie il s'était déjà
barré avec les mecs de la veille
ok on s'est retrouvé dans l'aéroport qui
s'éteignait petit à petit quelques
boubou qui fuyaient encore au bout comme
ça tout comme de cons avec le chamelier
a dit viens on tourne en argile bas et
puis sous une tache de lumière il y
avait une jeune femme en train d'écrire
donc on s'est rapprochés et cette jeune
femme n'écrivait pas le destinait puis
quand elle me voit le faire je viens de
chez vous si vous quoi lundi j'étais à
saint louis
je vous ai cherché partout alors j'ai
fait les jeudis vous avez fait les
dessins
dit oui elle me fait voir les dessins de
2 208 son interprétation de saint louis
et sur la couverture surtout cette
maison que je veux acheter pour en faire
un orphelinat pour les talibés ça veut
dire talibés les petits enfants de la
rue voilà et qui est encore en attente
d'achat c'est charteau suisse et en
france à sochaux il ya un livre qu'on a
pas évoquer encore parce qu'il est
encore dans les limbes il encore en
projet où il est déjà grisé jalil est
encore ici là un titre bulambo alors ça
s'écrit comme bon goût lambeaux baboo bo
é té lambeaux comme un lambeau la langue
qu'est ce que ça va être ça va déboulant
bon ça veut dire ça va être le début du
prochain libre
ça va être des nouvelles qui ont été
publiées à 25 ans ça va avec des bouts
de poèmes
ça va être une explication sur pourquoi
écrire pourquoi pourquoi quoi
et puis ça va être des pointes d'autres
aussi des petits potes à moi
d'accord j'ai des petits potes qui font
des poèmes magnifique
adieu mettre la petite photo je vais
expliquer qu'ils y sont il y aura leur
texte voilà ce petit bol pour
matérialiser un coup de colère coup de
gueule
béchard en pousse des coups de gueule
alors lequel ce soir il ya notre pote du
dal qui m'a laissé un message au
logement
ouais parce qu'on va arriver à la
période des expulsions et le printemps
revient à temps donc je serai à ses
côtés parce que moi j'aime pas beaucoup
quand même
on me mente avec autant d'acharnement
parce qu'on nous ment il n'y a pas de
logements sociaux à paris
je suis assez anormal que des gens qui
travaillent n'est pas un domicile n'est
pas une maison si ces mêmes donc ainsi
de cet institut est ainsi de suite donc
je serai à côté du dal le jour où j'ai
besoin de toi j'arrive on vient expulsé
en fin de concert là c'est que le
printemps qui est une belle saison il
faut se rappeler que c'est
c'est la saison des expulsions c'est la
saison à voir dès que les fleurs
poussent et ben on vire les peaux les
fleurs sont aux riches donc richard sera
là au début du printemps pour pas qu'on
les oublie
puis non j'adore toute la démarche de
josiane balasko depuis des années des
années cette femme se bat j'aime
beaucoup
voilà bah si un artiste une artiste a le
droit de se mêler de la vie civique eux
d'eux des citoyens
il n'y a pas deux je suis un artiste je
vais pas me mêler de politique c'est la
pire des bêtises parce que si on a un
artiste on est d'abord un citoyen aussi
mais dis moi ça va pas me casser ma cote
avec non non non mais tu vas voir tu vas
voir tu vas tu sors ton un petit peu les
sujets qui fâchent
bah ouais non mais moi j'aime bien ces
voix là alors là c'est dans ciné live
ça commence bien aa c'est quoi sinon je
ne sais pas que le nom de ce magazine
provoqué les rires c'était en février
abbas est valaisanne sortie de moving
donc voilà bon âgées comme le poulain le
titre n'annonce rien qui va
effectivement à la vue de ce pool
ardennais qui se laisse dépérir parce
qu'on l'a séparé de sa môman mais que
richard bohringer palefrenier qui sait
si bien murmurer là où vous savez va
tenter de sauver
on a le crains qu'ils se hérisser les
naseaux qui clapotent dans l'ensemble et
dabo comprenez niait en patois c'est pas
du verlan et dépourvue d'un minimum de
second degré les personnages secondaires
ce départ dans la même panade je
rappelle que c'était dans ciné live et
que ces pommes le poulain et que c'est
sûrement signé par quelqu'un mais je
vais retrouver s'en faut voilà donc pas
s'essayer par ont senti alors sans foi
alors comme le poulain est un film belge
il faut savoir il faut que ce monsieur
ça sache que les belges sont très drôle
très spirituel et qu'ils ont fait de
fort belles choses aux lobbys et que ce
petit film comme le poulain n'était pas
fait pour lui
il était fait pour des tout petits
enfants mais pas pour monsieur aussi des
live à pour monsieur signer d'accord
pour des tout petits enfants et c'est un
film j'ai adoré faire parce que je les
passais dans les ardennes belges passer
un été avec les grands grands ardennais
de 850 kg et avec tom que j'ai vu n'être
que j'ai vu grandir que j'ai vu suivi
son premier galop dans les ardennes j'ai
vu tout ça avec des jeunes acteurs
belges formidable c'est un tout petit
movie que la belgique a adoré adoré et
évidemment qu ici on a un peu bourru
cité bah ouais alors en général comment
richard bohringer promis critique alors
comment elles sont avec les charbonnages
écrite et est-ce qu'il ya le savais pas
il ya ceux qui attendent avec de toute
façon je me fais souvent esquinté il ya
des spécialistes
il ya les spécialistes ou alors on les
trouve ou par exemple on les a trouvés
très très très très longtemps à libé
ouais bien sûr à libé 10 mm
il s'est même pas les costumes il
n'aimait pas la lumière il n'aimait pas
le décor est il rajoutait qui manquerait
plus de bord âgés mais pourquoi c'est
quoi c'est que bourrage et il est à
saisissable individuelles non c'est quoi
c'est olivier assayas qui était
introduit ce miroir pour dire
l'admiration qu'ils richard bohringer at
il décidé d'admirer ce soir john casella
est ce que je peux voir bien sûr alors
donc gloria parce que gloria sebok qui
sont quasiment inséparables gêna
rowlands et casa vitesse alors gloria le
problème de gloria pour moi en tous les
cas puis j'ai vu qu'il y avait d'autres
lascars qui pensaient la même chose
gloria c'est 35 minutes béton mais alors
à te filer le frisson à te faire
dégouliner et tout va d'abord une
trouille mais c'est une trop humaine
c'est pas une trouille du monstre c'est
pas une trouille tu vois 2 1 c'est la
troupe de ce que peuvent être les
humains quand ils ont décidé d'être
mauvais
tu as la trouille et puis après bon
c'est la suite de cette femme avec un
gamin pour fuir la mafia 35 minutes
boum-boum km mais derrière il ya toute
l'oeuvre
il ya tout humain de ce mec est toute
une histoire du cinéma
alors les grands titres là les gros
titres ce qui bouge un bookmaker chinois
l'influencent opening voilà et alors il
ya déjà il ya dès le départ il ya sa
répulsion du racisme et donc je crois
que ses fesses il ya une scène
incroyable où on voit pas qu'elle ait
calé noir et un blanc tombe amoureux
d'elle
donc un jour il va la chercher chez elle
sans lui dire écoute elle ouvre la porte
lui y voit derrière le frère noir le
père noir
il a compris et elle lui dit donc c'est
pas le faire magnifique mais alors
est-ce qu'il ya par la fascination qu on
a beaucoup pour kasab est est ce couple
et c'est cette passion vécue à 2
est ce qu'on a on en rêve pas de dépôts
tous moi je pense que ouais on a tous
sens on a tous envie de cette réussite
là qu'elle soit mouvementée bordélique
tout ce que tu veux si tu on a tous
envie d'être un homme si fou si fou de
faire dix films avec sa femme des films
avec sa femme et il n'aurait fait et
d'être séparé quasiment par la mort
c'est tout il ya que ça qui les a
séparés
[Musique]
cette caméra voilà pour nous emmener
dans un un moment d'intimité un moment
que richard bohringer envie d'évoquer
avec nous ce soir
[ __ ] il ya une caméra dans ma caméra
c'est là une mise en abyme anaïs de trop
là où elle adopte donc tous voulaient
que je te raconte un truc qui m'a oui la
côte j'étais petit je suis resté très
longtemps dans un immense hôpital avec
plein de petits gamins et de mon lit à
moi je voyais la barrière qui ouvrait
sur l'intérieur de l'hôpital
et par cette barrière le dimanche ceux
qui avaient des parents passaient par là
et moi j'ai attendu deux ans et demi
gabarier elle soit pour moi elle n'a
jamais été mais cela souvenir
bouleversant parce que toutes les
silhouettes étaient forcément celle de
ma grand mère
oui je les voyais tous la voyaient venir
tout le temps tout le temps on ne
pouvait pas la peau valable pas un rond
rien du tout c'était berck
elle connaît déjà des enveloppes la nuit
album c'est le jour s'agitent à lever
ouais c'est elle qui m'a sorti de la
merde oui
mamie bas des bisous toujours de toute
valeur là et au bout des deux ans qu'est
ce qui s'est passé au bout de deux ans
ben on on m'a ramené à paris
et puis là j'ai habité avec mamie est ce
que franchement aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
des jours cherbourg âgées il avoit mamie
il a eu sa silhouette hammami il ya des
fois ces derniers temps ouais je tu sais
on peut remplacer pas mal de choses dans
la vie on peut remplacer un père on peut
remplacer des frères tout ce qui est
masculin on peut le remplacer je crois
mais ce qui est féminin le remplace
jamais et là mais on l'aura place jamais
pour ça que j'ai choisi le sahel comme
maire et quand je vais au sahel
j'y vais comme un fils qui retourne voir
sa mère
alors ça sur cette très très belles
images
alors je parlais avec richard bohringer
de l'ultime conviction du désir c'est le
26 mars à 20h30 à à l'elysée montmartre
ou lisez l'ultime conviction du désir
chez j'ai lu
à l'aller on parle aussi de carnaby
sénégal avec virginie broquet c'est chez
arthaud est debout lambeaux et schaars
cheikh nahyane mais comme je te dirai
charge et m
[Musique]